We've already done all the hard work of creating our animation with our
update function.
Including things like filtering our data, removing and
adding any new elements that need to be placed on the page.
As well as dealing with the data binding key function which determined which
elements to add or remove, d3 has great support for built in transitions.
And all you need to do to make the transition smooth is use
d3's special built in functions.
One of which is transition which kicks off a transition.
And the second most used is the duration.
In this case we make our selection, we append anything that needs to
be appended, and then kick off a transition that takes 500 milliseconds.
And what actually changes during the transition?
Well that's what comes after it.
All of these attributes which move the circles and
set the radius take 500 milliseconds to complete and
operate on the enter selection and the circles we are appending.
So now when we're adding circles they'll transition more smoothly, but
also potentially more importantly we want the countries to transition smoothly.
So following the exact same syntax we
place transition with a duration of 500 milliseconds.
Right before we change the fill and the stroke of countries to update and
hide or show based on the year of the world cup.
I would say this is one reason to use D3's built in
style functions to add style to our elements rather than using CSS.
So we can have much more flexibility in how we animate and apply those styles.
As you can see here, the countries transition out and
in much smoother than they did before since we added the transition to
the styles applied to the countries as well as the circles.
As they come in and
get placed at the respective home countries they belong on top of.
And now that we have finished our map, or at least the animation of it,
we can start to see a little story unfolding.
Can you find a narrative in the graphic we've created?